bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 21 mai
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro de filcho votre magazine
d'actualité qui revient sur l'économie
locale on commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette
édition dans l'actualité de cette
semaine 130 entreprises du secteur de la
défense étaient réunies mercredi et
jeudi à la 14e édition du Forum
entreprise défense à satori parmi ellees
une douzaine d'entreprises illinoises
nous y étions la finale nationale des
Olympiades de sciences a eu lieu cette
semaine au technocentre de Renault à
guilloncour retour sur ce concours qui
met en avant l'industrie et enfin
portrait Christophe Robin a 30 ans il
vient d'être élu meilleur agriculteur
d'Île-de-France au concours
talentgourmand il nous a présenter ses
volailles et cette semaine nous allons
parler du site internet localement vôtre
il a vu le jour il y a un peu plus d'un
an et réunit et recense tous les
producteurs et créateurs et créateurs
pardon yelinois avec nous pour en parler
en plateau Ann lor Leborne créatrice du
site internet localement vôre et
Marie-Pierre frez créatrice de bijou qui
est également recensé sur le site nous
allons parler avec vous de l'aventure
localement vôtre mais avant cela passons
en revue l'actualité de la
semaine le secteur de l'industrie et de
la défense était à l'honneur cette
semaine mercredi et jeudi à Versailles
la 14e édition du Forum entreprise des
fonds s'est organisé organisée pardon
conjointement par le simt la structure
intégrée du maintien en condition
opérationnel des matériels terrestres et
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
d'Île-de-France sur les 130 entreprises
présentes une douzaine é ti linoise un
reportage réalisé sur place avec Patrick
Jacques de de dixmud et Anna
Jimenez c'est l'innovation phare du
forum entreprise défense cette grande
tente accueille un char et peut même
loger un petit avion de combat
l'entreprise iinoise Nexter system
située à satori l'a conçu pour être
installé en 12h par les militaires en
opération extérieure ce qui est
intéressant pour l'armée maintenant
c'est d'avoir des matériels qui sont
très facilement et très rapidement
entretenables réparables et cetera et
l'occasion en fait a été présentée à
exter justement de pouvoir dans cette
optique là de faire un BAT lifft un
atelier projetable qui permet donc avec
des conteneurs que l'armée utilise déjà
pour ses opérations d'extérieur de
présenter un garage avec un pont de 10
tonnes qui permet d'tourner la tourelle
du VBCI par exemple ou de soulever un
GMP un groupe moto propulseur sur le
même véhicule autour d'autre véhicule
toutes les sociétés présentes cherchent
les faveurs de l'armée le client
principal du forum cette entreprise
ivlinoise basée à Montini le Bretonneux
doit comme les autres s'adapter à la
demande la problématique c'est une
problématique d'être efficace dans le
soutien d'avoir des matériels solides et
disponibles parce que si on doit les
utiliser c'est quand même mieux s'il
marche là on a des discussion voilà sur
le maintien en condition opérationnelle
qui est un enjeu les matériels sont
beaucoup utilisés donc il faut faire des
révisions et puis pour certains faut les
rénover aussi c'est une problématique
plutôt de d'évolution de rénovation que
de que de complètement d'innovation ce
qui nous intéresse surtout c'est
l'équipement et l'environnement du
combattant voà son équipement c'est tout
ce qui peut porter sur lui les casques
les lunettes l'armement les piles et
cetera donc tout tout ce qui est je
dirais moderne et et alléger nous
intéresse dans cette édition certains
produits peu plébisiter auparavant comme
le textile madeine France
réussissent à tirer le épingle du jeu
avec un chiffre d'affair à l'export de 5
milliards d'euros la France est un
acteur majeur du secteur de l'industrie
de la défense et le 4è pays exportateur
à l'échelle mondiale le contexte
budgétaire bien sûr nous
impacte comme pour toutes les industries
je pense l'armement on est surtout à
l'heure actuelle on est impacté par
par l'opération
sentinelle il y a une baisse d'activité
et dans les régiments et dans les dans
les centres d'entraînement pour répondre
bien sûr à la sécurité du territoire
hein le secteur concentre 700
entreprises en Île-de-France et 40000
emplois direct il a été fortement
impacté par les événements du mois de
janvier dernier et les actuelles
questions
d'économie et dans un tout autre
registre je vous en parlais dans les
émissions précédentes le deuxème trophée
de l'entrepreneuriat au féminin a été
décerné ce lundi sur les neuf catégories
univlinoise a été récompensée parcequeal
logé c'est son nom elle a été primée
dans la catégorie P installé à
montinville elle conçoit des parfums
inspirés par les grandes pages de
l'histoire de France de Versailles à
l'Empire ses créations ont un certain
succès à l'étranger vous pouvez les
retrouver sur son sur son site
www.historiae AC un
ealf.fr et je vous le disait en titre la
finale nationale des Olympiades des
sciences de l'ingénieur s'est déroulée
le 20 mai au technocentre de Renault à
Guill encour cette compétition a réuni
60 équipes de lycéens venus de toute la
France elle vise notamment à valoriser
le métier d'un ingénieur et le secteur
de l'industrie Michel midoro et William
l des drones des robots une m
artificielle qui fonctionne à distance
avec des contractions musculaires
bienvenue à la finale nationale des
Olympiades de sciences de l'ingénieur
cette 6e édition est organisé pour la
première fois dans l'entre du
technoocentre Eno à guencour 60 équipes
composé chacune de quatre à 5 lycéens
ont été sélectionné pour ce grand
rendez-vous ce sont les meilleurs
lycéens de France les lycéens suivent un
enseignement de sciences de l'ingénieur
aujourd'hui nous avons les 300 meilleurs
lycéens de France ils ont déjà été
présélectionnés dans des finales
académiques partout en France y compris
dans les départements de tremer chaque
année nous organisons cet événement donc
chaque année nous avons la possibilité
de montrer qu'en France nos jeunes ils
ont du talent parmi les jeunes présents
sur l'événement retrouvent Mathieu
Tournier et ses collaborateurs ses
lycéens originaires de Lyon ont inventé
le vol sans parachute donc ici l'avion
évoluant avec une vitesse dans ce sens
il suffit d' accélérer la personne dans
le sens inverse donc au départ la
vitesse de cet homme est comme celle de
l'avion dans ce sens ensuite en
accélérant cette personne la vitesse
réduit pe se réduit petit à petit pour à
la sortie de la soute avoir une vitesse
horizontale nulle il ne reste plus que
la vitesse verticale du à la hauteur de
chute donc ici euh Guillaume va appuyer
sur les boutons qui vont pouvoir de
pouvoir libérer la ventouse magnétique
et à la libération de du magnétisme de
l'aventouse la planche et tout ce
système sur le chariot en translation va
partir vers l'avant de la
pre la musique était également à
l'honneur lors de cet événement avec le
G piano l'innovation fonctionne avec des
interrupteur installé sur le bout des
doigts un produit qui aura sûrement
beaucoup plus à beoven ou à Deb on a
juste à s'imaginer un piano devant soi
on met le gant et on
joue
ces prodiges des algorithmes pourrai
intégrer les plus grands groupes
mondiaux dans quelques années et leurs
innovations pourrai être commercialisé
j'ai
vu un système qui permet de détecter les
chutes avant qu'ell ne se produisent et
nous qui cherchons à réduire les
accidents du travail dans nos
établissements c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui on peut creuser pour regarder
si on pourrait l'appliquer cette année
le premier prix a été attribué à la
prothèse de main robotisée fabriqué par
le lycée sainteroix d'Orléan piano a lui
terminé à la seconde place du
classement et nous allons parler
maintenant de création et de production
locale avec notre entretien de la
semaine c'est tout de
suite et je vous le rappelle nous sommes
en plateau avec Annelore Leborgne et
Marie-Pierre Perrez pour parler de cet
engouement pour les produits et les
créateurs locaux annel Leborgne vous
êtes je le rappelle la créatrice de
localement vôre et Marie-Pierre vous
êtes une des créatrices référencées sur
le site internet alors Anor vous étiez
venu il y a un an pour nous parler de la
création de ce site internet localement
vôtre quel bilan faites-vous maintenant
comment ça s'est un petit peu passé
depuis un an Al c'est une aventure
formidable chaque semaine j'ai le
plaisir de découvrir de de nouveaux
entrepreneurs avec des nouvelles idées
des nouveaux concepts et tout ça dans
les Yveline et je me fais un plaisir de
rédiger un billet dans mon blog sur
chacun d'eux sur leur vie leur passion
et et c'est je m'amuse beaucoup et je
SNE les Zeline pour découvrir tous ces
entrepreneurs alors vous avez maintenant
à peu près 150 créateurs et producteurs
sur le blog ce qui est quand même voilà
assez assez important euh vous les
rencontrz comment et d'ailleurs comment
vous avez rencontrer Marie-Pierre si
vous pouvez nous en parler comment ça se
passe un petit peu Marie-Pierre je l'ai
rencontré sur un marché local euh à mole
là où je vis elle elle était créatrice
et elle exposait ses créations donc euh
sur le marché nous avons discuté et on a
sympathisé immédiatement et puis nous
sommes nousous sommes aussi croisés
énormément dans de des réseaux
professionnels et depuis nous créons des
nous nous nousons des partenariats en
permanence ensemble alors Mariepierre au
début vous créez des bijoux voilà de
votre côté vraiment c'était votre
activité jusqu'au moment vous avez
rencontré marieor est-ce que ça Annelore
pardon ça ça a un petit peu décollé oui
alors l'avantage de de travailler comme
ça en partenariat c'est que ça étend les
possibilités c'est tout tout l'intérêt
je dirais oui parce que le fait d'être
référencé sur son blog me permet d'avoir
davantage de visibilité on peut créer
des offres commerciales ensemble donc
tout ça ça ça génère davantage de
possibilités de vendre c'est une
plateforme de visibilité importante
localement vôre ça vous permet vraiment
de vous faire connaître il a des gens
qui viennent vous voir en vous disant
voilà j'ai vu le site oui oui tout à
fait en plus on a on a aussi fait des
offres commerciales donc qui incitait
effectivement les gens à à aller sur son
blog et à venir après vers moi en disant
voilà je suis venue de la part de
localement vôtre il pouvait bénéficier à
ce moment-là d'une réduction donc oui
clairement et puis les gens ils veulent
consommer aussi autrement donc c'est
c'est un blog qui devient important pour
nous
créateurs vous étiez donc enfin vous
avez maintenant donc 150 créateurs
producteurs Mariepierre vous créz des
bijoux qu'est-ce qui fonctionne le mieux
est-ce que voilà c'est des produits du
terroir est-ce que c'est de voilà de de
l'épicerie fine est-ce que c'est des
bijoux est-ce que c'est de la décoration
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne le mieux
qu'est-ce qui attire le plus les gens
alors ce qui attire le plus les gens
c'est pas tant le produit que l'histoire
des gens et l'humain derrière en fait
les gens qui veulent consommer local
cherchent comment la personne qui qui a
créé le produit qui a qui a moissonné
qui a fabriqué qui a et et donc il
recherche vraiment l'histoire et c'est
ça qui intéresse les gens il cherchent
un produit un produit vivant parce que
du coup il y a aussi des peintres sur le
blog il y a vraiment une grande palette
si je puis dire d'artisans c'est aussi
le retour de l'artisanat un petit peu
alors je pense que l'artisanat a
toujours existé euh mais par aujourd'hui
les artisans travaillent dans l'ombre il
fut une époque où ils avaient tous leur
échop dans les rues aujourd'hui dans les
ivelines on ne voit plus ça et on les on
les crois sur les marchés artisanaux sur
les marché de Noël dans des salons mais
ils n'ont plus de boutique réellement il
en existe quelques-unes encore fort
heureusement mais c'est pour ça que le
blog peut les mettre en exerg et et
montrer aux yvelinois que oui il existe
des produits made in yelin c'est c'est
compliqué de faire des produits
justement mine Eveline pour vous
Mariepierre alors c'est pas compliqué de
les faire ce qui est compliqué et ça je
pense que c'est valable dans toutes les
régions de France c'est c'est d'en vivre
parce que quand on est créateur on doit
être multicasquette et c'est pas
forcément évident parce que moi j'ai pas
de salarié je travaille toute seule
c'est le cas de bon nombre de créateurs
yvelinois mais partout en
France voilà c'est c'est ça qui qui est
difficile c'est de trouver des des
moyens de pouvoir vendre des moyens de
faire de la pub et tout ça
dans un contexte qui est pas toujours
très facile et où nous créateurs on n
pas forcément des gros moyens donc c'est
pour ça qu'on essaie de travailler en
réseau pour tisser des des liens de plus
en plus grands et réussir à faire des
choses tous ensemble chacun dans notre
petit corps de métier et justement les
points clés en fait les les les points
importants qu'il faut savoir peut-être
avant de se lancer dans la création
quels sont-ils selon vous moi je je
dirais on en parlait encore tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il faut savoir où où
on veut aller clairement voilà être bien
organisé et puis savoir s'entourer pas
rester seul finalement être isolé c'est
c'est la plus grosse faiblesse en fait
je dirais et puis après c'est le reste
fait son chemin oui moi j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de créateurs le principal
problème en fait c'est c'est l'isolement
ils me disent moi je suis petit parce
que souvent les personnes travaillent
seul je suis face à mon ordinateur pour
ma commun comation face à mes produits à
créer et ensuite je dois vendre mais où
trouver les clients où trouver les
partenaires et c'est pour ça que mon
blog permet cette interactivité grâce à
au local club par exemple qui permet aux
petits entrepreneurs de se rencontrer de
parler de sujet vraiment spécifique à à
la toute petite entreprise et justement
donc les personnes référencées sur votre
blog voilà c'est beaucoup de produits
locaux c'est vraiment très hyper local
on peut dire est-ce que voilà il y a un
essort important vous vous constatez ça
vous analysez comment justement cette
affection de plus pour le l'hyper local
vraiment des des choses qui sont
produits vraiment dans leur département
je pense que c'est la la tendance
nationale aujourd'hui le made in France
fait beaucoup parler de lui je voyais
Benjamin Carl qui a qui a le journaliste
qui a vécu en 1 an en made in France on
sort un livre en ce moment c'est
vraiment une vogue c'est très c'est très
important en ce moment et les gens
recherchent donc le made in France mais
l'hyper local aussi donc le département
et il n'y a aucune aucune façon de le
trouver aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics
n' n'ont pas pris ça réellement en main
pour montrer faire une liste un annuaire
des entrepreneurs et des créations et
donc il est nécessaire pour les
ivelinois d'avoir un endroit pour pour
le trouver bien voilà c'est grâce à des
initiatives comme ça avec que on arrive
justement à remettre au goût du jour les
produits locaux vous lancez d'ailleurs
avec local mon vôre une initiative c'est
ça bientôt il me semble oui alors je
lance le local malin notamment avec
Marie-pierre alors l'idée c'est que les
ivilinois recherchent en permanence donc
tous ces créateurs locaux ils sont pas
évident à trouver car il sillonne les
ivelines à travers plusieurs marchés
artisanaux mais l'idée c'est de de faire
bénéficier aux ivelinois grâce à une
carte qui sera donné donc par le local
malin une carte qui fera bénéficier à
tous ces détenteurs d'offres
commerciales chez les entrepreneurs
locaux qui participe bien nous
retrouverons certainement toutes ces
informations sur le blog de localement
vôre merci beaucoup annel et Mariepierre
d'être venu avec nous sur notre plateau
je vous propose de continuer l'émission
avec le chiffre de la
semaine
2,85 million d'euros c'est notre chiffre
de la semaine c'est le montant total des
impôts prélevés dans le département pour
faire votre déclaration de papier il est
trop tard mais si comme la moitié des
ivelinois vous préférez Internet vous
avez un petit surcis car la date limite
est fixée au 9 juin enfin sachez que
dans notre département 22,9 % des
ménages sont exonérés d'impôt alors que
7164 foyers P l'ISF l'impôt sur la
fortune je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre partie magazine avec
l'entrepreneur de la
semaine et elle était venue justement en
plateau l'année dernière pour parler de
local monvôtre Sabine bataillet a créé
il y a 2 ans son site internet desich
box où elle proposait des boxes
personnalisé à offrir elle s'est fait
justement connaître grâce à localement
vôre et aujourd'hui elle a sa propre
boutique à plaisir nous sommes allés lui
rendre visite un reportage réalisé avec
Patrick Jacques du xmud et Romain Rin au
montage
une boutique une vraie entre bijouterie
décoration et épicerie F ce n'est pas
sans fierté que Sabine nous accueille
dans son magasin ouvert depuis le 1er
décembre à plaisir un vrai changement
pour cette ancienne secrétaire de
direction devenu son propre patron j'ai
commencé mon aventure il y a 2 ans au
moyen d'un site
internet je regroupa différentes boxes
avec des thématiques comme naissance
pour les hommes pour les femmes des
boxes beauté en essayant intégrer un
maximum de produits créateurs et tout
particulièrement des produits des
zivelines au bout de 2 ans j'ai eu
l'opportunité de prendre un magasin dans
les Yvelines les créateurs sont plus
nombreux qu'on pourrait l'imaginer
aujourd'hui Sabine a plus d'une dizaine
de fournisseurs à ses débuts c'est
anlord Leborgne avec son site localement
vautre qui lui a donné un petit coup de
pouce pour son entreprise elle était un
petit peu mon fournisseur officiel de
partenaire également car j'ai rencontré
ben un certain nombre de mes
fournisseurs actuels grâce à elle comme
ça a été le cas pour les gâteaux les
gâteaux que je vends actuellement dans
mon magasin je les ai connu grâce à elle
car elle avait été les interviewé elle
les trouvé fantastique elle m'a dit il
faut que tu viennes avec moi absolument
les goûter donc ça me permet voilà de
rencontrer tout un tas de gens que je
n'aurais pas connu ou que j'aurais pris
beaucoup plus de temps à trouver toute
seule une démarche qui plaît de la
visibilité il n'en fallait pas davantage
pour que Sabine vendre ses boxes dans
une vraie boutique en réservant quelques
étagères pour ses nouvelles trouvailles
les fameuses box dont on parlait je me
suis lancé il y a 2 ans où là par
exemple on est sur une idée de box à la
vanille vous avez du savon à la vanille
une bougie artisanale vanille du thé à
la vanille je travaille avec une
créatrice à Chevreuse qui fait que des
savons artisanaux donc ce sont des
savons 100 % naturels et d'ailleurs elle
a reçu plusieurs prix de l'Observatoire
des cosmétiques cette année ici du café
de Joris FAF le Tor factacteur de Triel
sur scè Sabine l'a découvert sur un blog
elle la R contrer avant de tester ses
produits auprès du public et de les
proposer à temps plein dans sa boutique
un moyen de fidéliser sa clientèle tout
en proposant des nouveauté du coin
acheter local plus qu'une mode une
nouvelle façon de consommer on a envie
de soutenir le petit producteur près de
chez soi parce qu'on a pas envie qu'il
arrête de faire ce qu'il fait vu qu'il
le fait bien dire peut-être que je vais
pas acheter 10 paquets de gâteaux dans
le mois je va peut-être en acheter que
deux mais j'en veux deux ou ce sont des
œufs frais bio de feucherol
ou je sens le vrai goût du miel quand je
croque dans mon biscuit voilà Sabine
fait attention au prix de ses produits
afin de rester accessible elle réalise
90 % de ses ventes en boutique à présent
contre 10 % sur son site internet moi
j'ai fait un objectif à peu près sur
l'année de 80000
€ en base après c'est compliqué quand on
ouvre parce qu'on n' pas un chiffre
d'affaires précédent pour se rendre
compte et pour l'instant c'est bien
parti la jeune chef d'entreprise
aimerait se lancer dans le concept de
magasin éphémère avec d'autres créateurs
évelinois mais pas d'inquiétude quant à
la boutique de la ferme des ébisoirs
celle-ci Sabine compte bien la garder
ouverte et nous restons dans la
production locale avec le métier de la
semaine c'est tout de
suite il a été élu meilleur agriculteur
d'Île-de- France Christophe Robin a 30
ans il évit il élève des volailles à la
ferme de la unière à son champ dans vin
ce jeune agriculteur a été distingué il
y a quelques semaines pour la 2e édition
du Prix talent gourmand de 2014 organisé
en partenariat avec le Crédit Agricole
il privilégie une une agriculture
responsable et maîtrisée c'est notre
métier de la semaine reportage avec
Patrick Jacques de dixmud et Romain
resppiné pour le
montage derrière le volant de ce
tracteur se cache le meilleur
agriculteur d'île-de-fance Christophe
Robin élève près de 2000 volailles à son
champ dans les Yvelines son TI titre il
le doit à ses petites protégées alors il
s'en occupe bien et ça commence par
l'alimentation aujourd'hui c'est c'est
la la richesse de mon de de ce que je
peux produire c'est qu'on a la chance de
pouvoir apporter les aliments de la
ferme et aujourd'hui bah c'est quelque
chose auquel je tenais ça me gênait
quand j'ai fait cette démarche de de me
dire je vais aller acheter les aliments
à la coopérative ça va être tout prèt
tout non là ce qu'il faut c'est du local
on est dans cette logique son mélange de
céréales sans OGM Christophe le
distribue lui-même pas de machine
automatisée seulement deux races de
poulet de souche rustique cohabite
l'éleveur s'occupe seul de ces volatiles
avec de la passion du Grand a un peu de
système D mais aussi de la rigueur j'ai
pas de la belle moi mais je suis le
cahier des charges de la Chambre
d'agriculture qui dit que c'est une
production fermière qui dit production
fermière dit volaille donc élevée en
plein air accès au parcours croissance
lente les céréales de la ferme et avec
un minimum d'élevage de 90 jours
je suis souvent au-delà de ça le mois
dernier j'ai sorti des volailles qui
faisaient entre 120 et 130 jours et là
on avait des poulets qui viaient entre 2
kg5 et 3 kg quoi mais voilà au moins on
a des des volailles qui sont qui sont
charnu ça fait plaisir à voir il fait
partie de cette nouvelle génération
d'agriculteurs raisonnés une
exploitation de 200 hectares diversifié
et des volailles en complément le lauréa
du concours talon gourmand s'est lancé
dans l'aventure en 2012 pas vraiment une
conversion pour ce trentenaire c'est un
choix de vie moi ça me plaît bien parce
que j'avais un métier dans lequel avant
j'étais commercial et bah aujourd'hui
grâce à ce cette activité volail bah un
je garde mes racines d'agriculteur par
mes parents et deux bah je continue ma
passion quelque part de de Relation
Clientèle je trouve c'est sympa de
pouvoir offrir quelque chose qu'on
maîtrise à ses clients donc moi mes
volaill tant que j'ai rien à faire ben
je fais rien donc j'interviens que si je
risque de perdre mes volailles à part du
fermifuge je ne fais rien sur mes bets
au début je me suis pas la question de
savoir comment j'allais vendre je me
suis dit ah faut que je me lance faut
que je produise il arrivé un moment là
faut peut-être quand même penser à la
distribution la commercialisation pas
plus de 450 volailles en même temps dans
son pavillon de 60 m²r pour éviter les
maladies en extérieur ces animaux
disposent de 2 m Carr chacun minimum
pour lui une garantie de la qualité du
produit en pour savoir si le poulet est
bon alors bah on regarde un petit peu en
dessous donc là on je vous l'ai dit
c'est des poulets qui sont assez jeunes
et qui sont pas encore très développés
mais voilà on touche ici puis quand bah
quand c'est bien rond bien rempli bah on
sent pas trop le la pointe ici le brchet
80 % de ces poulets sont vendus en
circuit court Christophe travaille avec
des réseaux locaux comme la map de
plaisir les marché fermier ou encore la
boucherie du château à
rouiller où est-ce que je te mets
ça Christophe travaille ses volailles
les gens peuvent aller voir ses
volailles dans les champs directement
nous on peut aller sélectionner nos
volailles quand il est prêt à à nous
recevoir ou voir plein de choses
ensemble c'est le côté proximité qui est
très important quoi nous c'est vraiment
ce qu'on cherche parce que de toute
façon on est dans tous ces produits un
petit peu d'exception que ce soit le
poulet que ce soit le jambon que ce soit
des choses comme ça on veut vraiment des
produits nous qui qui rappelle les
anciens produits mais au goût du jour en
plus de son titre 5000 € ont été
attribués à Christophe un moyen pour le
jury de professionnels d'encourager ce
type d'exploitation un modèle bien
différent de l'élevage co français en
moyenne 40 jours d'élevage pour 16000
volailles à l'année et c'est bientôt la
fin de notre émission mais avant de nous
quitter je vous propose de regarder avec
moi à l'agenda de la
semaine
et deux dates à ne pas rater dans notre
agenda cette semaine mardi 26 mai la
Cité des Métiers de 50 ans en ivine
organise un atelier sur le thème de
l'efficacité dans la recherche de
l'emploi cet atelier se déroule de 9h30
à 11h30 il vous propose de définir votre
rapport a temp vos priorités les
imprévus et votre semaine type autant de
facteurs déterminants dans dans
l'efficacité de votre recherche d'emploi
enfin si vous souhaitez en savoir plus
sur la ligne 18 du Métro Grand Paris
Express une réunion d'information est
organisée par la Société du Grand Paris
sur le projet de la ligne 18 qui reliera
l'aéroport d'Orly à la gare de
Versailles-Chantier en passant par le
plateau de saclai et Saint-Quentin en
ivine elle a lieu le mercredi 27 mai à
19h30 au pavillon valdecrousseau à
guilloncour c'est maintenant la fin de
notre émission merci de nous avoir suivi
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine à la même heure pour un
nouveau numéro de filecho je vous
souhaite une très bonne
soirée